speaking of vaccines and mandates and
masks and young people we knew it was
coming we knew it was coming and then I
saw this this morning masks are coming
back from mlive.com It's
michiganlive.com News masks will now be
required while indoors in Ann Arbor
Public Schools from January 9th to
January 20th for all students staff and
visitors in order to combat a surge of
illnesses as students return from break
yes it is happening right now and I
would say to the people of Michigan
well not if you're someone watching this
and you're from Michigan because then I
have sympathy with you but I think you
should go but everyone else you voted
for Gretchen Whitmer again you did you
brought back the same governor who was
one of the worst you know you got your
Newsome you got your Kathy hochel you
got your Gretchen Whitmer the trifecta
of evil related to covid but you guys
re-elected
I was gonna I was gonna say the b word I
was going to say the b word I'll try
it's Monday you you re-elected that
witch
that was good you re-elected that witch
and that's what you get here's Whitmer
back in September of 2020 uh and
listened to her when she's talking about
uh Bill Barr who was against these crazy
Federal lockdowns and everything else so
U.S should stay at home orders early in
the pandemic and you have not ruled out
issuing them again if there's a big jump
there the Attorney General Bill Barr
spoke out about that sort of order today
here's what he said
you know
putting a national lockdown stay-at-home
orders is like house arrest it's not
it's the it's you know other than
slavery which was a different kind of
restraint this is the greatest intrusion
on civil liberties in American history
greatest intrusion on civil liberties in
American history
what do you make of a comparison to
slavery
I mean I just think the Attorney General
was unhinged and it is deeply disturbing
that our chief law enforcement officer
is promulgating this kind of
craziness the fact of the matter is
the the worst thing that we can do for
another American is to give them a virus
that could kill them that's the biggest
violation of our civil rights is an
Administration and a government that is
undermining our ability to protect
ourselves and our lives and our
livelihoods
first off he did not compare it to
slavery right he did not compare slavery
he was saying slavery was that this is
something else altogether okay that's
number one putting that aside for a
moment she's evil she's evil but the
people of Michigan voted her in so they
signaled to the evil woman can you do
more evil to us and that's why it will
come back in New York and it will come
back in Cali I have great sympathy for
any of you watching this that you're
there and
in Michigan or your kids are at an Ann
Arbor school and you don't want them in
this it's up to you right now it is up
to you to either take your kid out of
school or start homeschooling or leave
the state take your family and your
skills and your resources and your
goodness and your sense of community and
pride and and belief in America and
American exceptionalism whatever it
might be and move to a Freer place and
strengthen these places because these
people will not stop because they have
been given the signal via elections that
people want more and more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]